Yeah.
So back to where you were saying before
about the striving upwards towards
something that happened up there,
whatever that is.
Um,
of course we don't want to go for utopia
because there's no such place to get to
and that causes catastrophes in history.
So,
but the idea of like,
of like making the world
a more rational place,
this is a good goal.
And this is the kind of thing
that we do at skeptic magazine.
I what did we do?
We promote science and
reason and critical thinking.
You write about critical thinking,
this is what you do.
So we're all working on that
and that and and that's good.
Um,
yeah.
Well I'm always looking at,
sorry,
go ahead.
We'll be talking about
literature for example.
It's returned to the books of the Bible
or dusty SD or if we want to make our
listeners' heads explode,
iron rand and atlas shrug.
Why have people by the tens of
millions purchased her books?
You know,
literary critics say they're awful,
they're terrible.
Novels are not well written and her
figures are black and white and her
philosophy is wrong.
Okay,
let me,
you have to ask yourself,
why do tens of millions of
people love those books?
And,
and it's because she's
doing something else.
He's not trying to describe the
world the way it actually is,
but that the way it could be.
And these are the things we've done wrong.
Communism,
socialism,
because she came out of
that Russian background.
And so her figures like John Golf,
these are kind of ideal
things to strive for.
Yes,
exactly.
Her fingers are archetypal
heroes of a certain form.
If we could bring it back
to some real world example,
I just recently,
recently started following
a Jocko Willink feel,
okay,
I'm never going to be Jocko Willink,
but you know,
I got this book and I read
one page a day and it,
you know,
it's kind of,
it's sort of like,
oh yeah,
you can get up at six in the morning
and get out there on your bike ride with
the guys.
I don't want to do it.
But then I see his page
and he's just get at it.
Okay.
So in a way,
it's not describing the
world in a scientific way.
It's,
it's,
it's sending a different message,
like you should strive to be this,
even if you don't make it,
just do it.
Do something.
Anything.
And that's a different
sense of different goal.
Yes.
Well I,
I think to that.
Okay.
So first of all,
with regards to any round,
I think the criticism leveled at her that
her characters are too black and white
is correct.
Because I think that one of the things
that distinguishes great literature from
propaganda is that in great literature,
most of the conflict is
within rather than between.
Right?
And so,
and the problem with the round is all
her good characters are the same good
character and all her bad characters
are the same bad character.
And,
and there's no overlap between them.
So there's a curiosity,
there's an architectural purity,
but that compromises its
utility as literature.
I would say
Soltra Neeson makes his point
in archipelago where he says,
if only the world,
we're simply black and white and
we can take the bad people and,
and,
and isolate them somewhere.
But the problem is,
is,
you know,
we all have a darkness
and evil in our hearts
between good and evil runs
down every hard doubts,
his famous sprays.
And it was something he experienced
very deeply and is also,
you know,
it's also pride,
primordial Lee true.
Whenever.
Awesome.
Just analyze literature in this sense.
Well,
there's a body of literature,
evolutionary,
you know,
literary analysis in which,
um,
you know,
peep pinker writes about this at the
end of the blank slate in which he talks
about,
you know,
these novels,
these sophisticated novels,
which the characters are rich and deep,
you know,
they have all these good
characters and bad characters,
characteristics and so on.
And uh,
and we can,
we can glean from that in a sense
that the novelists we're ahead of the
cognitive.
This is his point.
The novelists we're about a century
ahead of the cognitive scientists and
thinking that you're going to have human
nature or maybe a thousand years ahead
of
modern literature anyway,
you know,
so we can,
we can gain a lot from that.
Not just the rich emotional
experience of reading a good novel.
Uh,
but actually teasing out this is what
some of these evolutionary literary people
are trying to do.
It's like there's certain themes that
come up over and over and over again.
Uh,
it's not totally random.
Unlike the postmodernists there,
there actually are a certain real meanings
that the author intended and there
problem
c,
I think the problem with the
postmodernists technically speaking,
and I've thought a lot about this,
is that they got their
initial criticism right,
which is that there's an infinite number
of ways of interpreting a finite set of
phenomenon,
but there isn't an,
there isn't an,
there isn't an infinite number of valid
ways of interpreting a finite set of
phenomena.
And that's where you get right back
into the issue of the circulation of the
interpretation around these great
underlying architectural themes.
And then our belt in large
part right into our biology,
I read a really interesting
analysis of the,
um,
of the symbol of the dragon awhile back.
And I can't conjure up the
name of the book unfortunately,
but his hypothesis,
which I thought was a very good one,
was that,
um,
a dragon is a Metta Predator.
So it's the symbol for Predator and,
but it's more than that.
But the Predator is treat cat,
snake bird,
because the fundamental predators of
tree dwelling primates where cats,
snakes and birds.
And so what it is is an
amalgam of all those things.
And so it's real,
just like the category
of Predator is real,
even though snakes and cats are both
in the category of Predator and no one
says,
well,
there's no such thing as a predator.
And then you can add fire to
that for a variety of reasons,
not least being uh,
being I'm sure that fire white belt,
many of our ancestors as well.
And then the additional,
which is the dragon's also hoard gold.
So human beings,
because we're not just prey,
animals learned that if we
confronted the Metta Predator,
we would gain as a consequence.
There are certain channels down which
good stories go based on our biological
nature or evolved in nature.
It's not that it's completely
deterministic in that sense.
No,
no.
It's variations on a theme,
I would say.